Si no sabes cómo, pregunta.
Si tienes hijos--
(Risas)
ten conversaciones sobre sexo lo antes posible,
porque los niños ya no buscan s-e-x-o en el diccionario.
Lo buscan en internet.
Y al tener esas conversaciones,
no se centren el tema solo en la reproducción.
La gente tiene sexo por muchas razones,
algunos porque quieren un bebé,
pero la mayoría de nosotros porque se siente bien.
Admítanlo.
Y sin importar si una quiere tener hijos o no,
apoyen una educación sexual completa, que no humille a nuestros adolescentes.
(Aplausos)
Nada positivo resulta de humillar a adolescentes
por sus deseos sexuales o comportamiento,
aparte de tests de ETS y embarazo positivos.
Cada día se nos da la oportunidad
de interrumpir patrones de inequidad.
Creo que todos podemos estar de acuerdo en que vale la pena hacerlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)